i know you're wondering what coin
flipping
has to do with this k-mean clustering i
promise i will explain
in this section and in the previous
section
we learned that if hidden vector is
known
that we can derive parameters through
dot product
but in reality neither hidden vector no
parameters are known
and therefore it is unclear how to
derive the biases of the coin
let's start from a simple problem let's
imagine for a second
that parameters are actually no let's
start from these examples the parameters
are
0.35 for the blue coin 0.80
for the green coin can we derive the
hidden vector
well let's say what is the
most likely coin to generate the first
sequence of flip
where the fraction of heads is 0.4
well we can compute the probability that
the first sequence
was generated by the blue coin and this
probability turned out to be
0.00113
we can also compute the probabilities
that it was generated by
the green coin and it turned out to be
much smaller number
0.0003
with which coin is more likely of course
the blue coin
is more likely to generate the first
sequence
which coin is more likely to generate
the second sequence with these
nine heads well we do the same
calculation it turns out
that probability of the second series of
flips to be generated by the
blue coin is much smaller than the
probability of
it being generated by the green coin and
therefore
the most likely coin for the second
series of flips
is great and by continuing this way
we can derive the hidden vector
and it brings us to the following idea
yes we do not know parameters or hidden
vector
when we start evaluating the biases of
coin
but let's start from randomly chosen
parameters as soon as parameters are
chosen
we can derive the hidden vector as soon
as the hidden vector is derived we
question our wisdom
in selecting the initial parameters and
estimate the
parameters using data and hidden vector
as
i described before through the dot
product
in this way we will arrive to the new
parameters as soon as the new parameters
are
derived we once again to evaluate the
hidden vector
and iterate they came up with an
approximation algorithm
for evaluating parameters for the coin
flip
and let me show you how this algorithm
work
we start from randomly
selected parameters as soon as
parameters selected
we form a hidden vector so we assign
each series of flips to either blue coin
or red coin as soon as
a hidden vector is derived we can use
this hidden vector to derive new
parameters
soon as this new parameter is derived we
construct new hidden vector
and we iterate until convergence
does this algorithm remind you something
of course it is the k-means algorithm or
something very similar
to the lloyd algorithm in this car in
disguise
where are the data hidden vector and
parameters
in k-means clustering well data
are obviously the set of data points
what are the parameters parameters are
of course the positions of the centers
and what is the hidden vector hidden
vector is simply assignment of data
points
to k centers which is an n dimensional
vectors with coordinates from
1 to k this assignment hidden vector is
shown
below by green cardinals
so we figure out how to solve the coin
flipping problem and
how what relationship it has to k-means
clustering
and now we'll talk about more general
approach called
expectation maximization